send available cars to the area
a suspect is wanted in a murder
investigation
hey guys pete here this is my mayor of
east town
ending explained video we got a big
twist
which means i guessed wrong about a lot
of things
and we pretty much got answers to
everything all the major stuff anyway
no crucial questions left unanswered but
a little bit of lingering mystery
i'll break down everything that happened
what the ending means
and at the end of the video i'll talk
about what worked for me and what didn't
really quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched the entire mayor of east
town limited series all seven episodes
then this video won't be for you
and with that out of the way let's jump
right into it
with about 10 minutes remaining in the
finale of mayor of east town
her therapist reminds mare that she
throws herself
into cases as a way of delaying her own
grief about what happened to her son
kevin that's followed by the question do
you think you're ready now to face what
you're avoiding
i'll circle back around to explain the
setup for how we got there
but this is the core of what drives the
series it's got a main character who
peaked early
finds herself in a position of relative
small town
power she's not just a cop but a
detective
who's also kind of stuck where she's at
and she can't confront her grief
and it's real to be sure her son
struggles with mental illness
drug addiction and his eventual suicide
it's a lot to carry when you can't
forgive yourself
mayer's inability to move past it is
understandable
and at the same time we see how not
confronting that grief affects her life
and everyone around her
the big question is whether or not she
can confront her past and move on
we start out with answers about what
jess and dylan were up to
it turns out that burning the journals
was jess's idea
she was trying to keep aaron secret
about dj's real father from
coming out and in her own words she was
just trying to honor her friend
dylan went along with this because he
cared for dj but also knew that his
parents wanted to continue to raise the
child
and that it would break their hearts if
he was taken away from them
jess changed her mind and we learned
that the photos she gave to the chief as
proof
is a shot aaron took of herself in bed
with her cousin john
ross who's next to her asleep this is
confirmation that john was the father
and the chief confirms the motivations
for why jess and dylan did what they did
this concludes the jess and dylan story
except for a scene later that confirms
dylan's feelings for dj
he visits laurie's house after hearing
about the surgery
and gives her money he'd been saving
including the envelope he found in
aaron's room
at the river we see that jon is
struggling with his plan to kill his
brother
billy had agreed to confess to aaron's
murder but jon doesn't think that he can
trust him to hold up under questioning
at this point it's hard to figure out
why billy would go along with it in the
first place
billy understood that he brought the gun
and suspected that he might be trying to
kill him
and when he learns that that is jon's
plan he encourages him to do it that
he'd be doing him a favor
and we get the idea that jon convinced
his brother by telling him that he had a
family to look after while billy had no
one
he can't go through with it though and
when mayor arrives he turns the gun on
himself
billy jumps on him stops him from taking
his own life and as mare's cuffing him
john begs mare to just end his life
rather than taking him in
there's no need to look too closely at
what jon confessed to about the night of
the murder since we know that he wasn't
telling the truth
he does confirm that their relationship
and i say that with heavy air quotes
started at the reunion
he is remorseless about that and goes on
to tell them how he justified what he
was doing
saying that it was more than sex and
that they had a connection
and they could confide in each other and
blah blah blah
the kind of things you would expect
someone like that to say
if they found themselves in that kind of
situation
the other important thing that comes out
of this is that mayor asks if laurie
knew
and he says that he convinced her to lie
to her for him to tell her
it was billy that killed aaron later we
see john being arraigned
and he has a moment to talk to his wife
outside the courtroom
he asks her to take dj in and raise him
she doesn't say anything here but does
end up taking this on later
and after he leaves we see her and mayor
exchange a tense look
when she comes home helen asked if she
talked to laurie
and we learned that mare's pissed off
that she obstructed the investigation
and at this point the tension comes from
her thinking it was all to protect john
she has a heart to heart with siobhan
about going to berkeley
at first she just says it's her life she
can do what she wants but then when
she's pressed
she tells her she thinks she should go
they have a moment here
and that pretty much wraps up the
siobhan story but we do see her leave
towards the end of the episode
and how hard it is for everyone to say
goodbye
after jon's arrest time moves on and
several of the other plot points are
wrapped up
we see that dawn and beth helped katie
and kenzie
by giving them freddie's house i guess
that makes more sense than his family
moving back in where he died
we see that laurie finally gets poor
little dj his ear
surgery and in the process see that the
dj stands for dylan john
the custody dispute over drew comes to
an end when carrie relapses
mare and frank are waiting at the
mediators whenever she gets a call
mayor has a conversation with her as
she's getting ready to leave for the
treatment facility
things start to unravel with the case
when the family are all out together
with frank and faye
helen asked frank if he's talked to john
he says that he hasn't
and he talks about how he can't believe
john did what he did and he still took
them home
acting like nothing happened on the
night that aaron died
there's one of those family generational
moments
when we see helen mayer and siobhan
talking
helen breaks down crying after they talk
about mare's childhood
and how she took out a lot of her own
frustrations on her daughter
mare's noticeably uncomfortable but says
that she forgives her
and helen says that's what she really
wants for mare to be able to forgive
herself
about kevin because it wasn't her fault
that's one of those truths that you can
think
that you can hear someone else say that
you can intellectually know
is true but accepting it is a whole
different ballgame
and this is a major point that the
show's trying to make mare may know this
but she hasn't been able to forgive
herself she goes to the bathroom and
runs into sandra
in their conversation she learns that
jon wasn't
actually having an affair with her this
time and that makes her think more about
jon's story
so we see her go back and start watching
the tape listening to him talk about
not being able to remember what kind of
gun aaron had
while she's doing that we learn about
billy ross's fate
when the chief comes and tells her that
because he cooperated
he'll be eligible for parole the next
year frank is able to move on
he repaired his relationship with faye
and everyone attended their wedding
and there is a conclusion to richard's
storyline we see that mare and him get
together
things look pretty good but he had
already accepted a different
job so he's going away for a one-year
contract
and in the end he was just a nice guy
that came to town and fell for mayor
i suppose his leaving is essential in
mare's journey she needs to move on
and the way it's set up he's not a
necessary ingredient
in that recipe the big reveal the big
ending comes by the way of us going back
to where we started
mare's in bed and she gets a call from
betty carroll's number
and that's odd because betty's now dead
of course it's her husband
glenn and luckily his eagles mugged from
the championship
game and that really nice pizza cutter
he had went missing
also something strange happened with his
gun and when mayor hears it was a cult
detective special
that went missing briefly but then
returned
she wants to go see it as she's looking
at it
he tells her the other thing that's
crazy it was missing two rounds when it
reappeared
and when she hears that she wants to
know who has access to the shed
and it's a short list of suspects just
glenn himself
and the kid who cuts his grass who turns
out to be ryan
ross that revelation brings us back to
glenn's security camera
which showed up in the first episode and
continued to pop up throughout the
series
she checks the footage she's able to see
ryan sneaking into the shed on the night
of aaron's murder
there's a really nice touch here where
she makes an audible gasp when she
understands what she's seeing
putting the pieces together that her
best friend's son
is involved with the death of his
teenage cousin a single mom
who herself is the victim of sexual
abuse at the hands of a trusted family
member
she goes to a school and when he sees
her he flees
and that prompts her to go back to her
car and call it in
and we see that this crushes her she
drives to their house where ryan's
already told laurie that mare's coming
and everything the ross family did was
to protect
ryan and now that mayor's figured it out
the truth is gonna come out
it's a devastating situation these are
mare's people
she's close with the entire family and
it's her job to expose this teenager who
made a
crushing mistake and delivered justice
for aaron
at the station ryan gives a full
confession explaining what really
happened on the night aaron died
he found out about their relationship
again with the big air quotes
when he found text messages on his dad's
phone he told him that he would keep
that secret
if he ended the relationship the night
of frank's party he saw that it was
still going on
and when he found a message on the phone
that aaron wanted to meet him at the
park at midnight
ryan answered saying he'd be there
pretending to be jon
when the adults went to the bar ryan
went home he got his bike
he stopped on the way to the park at the
carols to grab the gun
which he knew was there because of his
grass cutting job
he says he just wanted to scare her and
that's obviously the truth he didn't go
there with the intention to kill her
being a kid he pointed the gun though he
had his finger on the trigger
he shouted at her to stay away from his
family how could you do this
and tragically she tried to take it away
from him they fought over it
it went off and when he regained control
he hit her with the fatal shot in the
face
he hid the body and called his dad later
jon came home and told him it was all
taken care of now and it was a secret
he made the strange choice of putting
the gun back because he didn't know what
else to do
he just thought that someone might find
it if he threw it somewhere
and maybe if he put it back no one would
ever notice that it was gone
and he had no idea that when he was
there the first time
glenn heard him went out to grab the gun
for protection as he does
and wasn't able to find it in the
interview they asked lori if she knew
she admits that jon came to her to tell
her that she had to lie to mayor about
it being billy that morning before mayor
arrived we saw that conversation we just
didn't see all of it
she says that she would have taken this
to her grave if mare wouldn't have come
to arrest ryan
and she's obviously telling the truth
here lori found herself in an impossible
situation
and chose to try to protect her son
which makes her decision something you
can understand
when asked if he has anything else to
say ryan just says that he's sorry
and they send him off to the juvenile
facility outside mayor goes to laurie
and tries to comfort her
and she just feels betrayed and doesn't
want anything to do with it
she's lost everything and she blames
mare for solving the case
she says you already had john why
couldn't you just leave it alone it's
ryan
my ryan it was an accident he doesn't
even know how to hold a gun
my whole family's gone because of you
get away from me i don't ever want to
see you again
this reminds you of the earlier
conversation they had on the bench
where lori says mare's pushing everyone
away but when asked he says no it won't
work on me because i won't let you
now laurie is pushing her away and won't
let mare be in her life
and through clearer eyes mayor can see
that she really lost everything because
of what her husband did
it's a tragic situation which all stems
from jon's criminal actions where
everyone around him loses
the lives of two young people are lost
one is dead and one is in prison
given the small town dynamic lori is
poised to become the town pariah
her presence is a reminder of what her
husband did
what her son did and everything that
goes along with that and people will
know she tried to cover it up
for the ending the show decides to shift
away from that
and focus on the bond between friends
that have a connection in their
tremendous
loss there's one last therapy session
when lori comes up she says she's called
and sent messages but they've gone
unanswered there's a seed planted here
and we come back full circle to the
question i opened the video with
do you think you're ready now to face
what you're avoiding
another seed is planted when deacon mark
gives a sermon talking about community
and how he feels things are turning
around in east town
he mentions that some people haven't
emerged with everyone else
and they find themselves on the outside
he says it's not for
us to decide if they're deserving our
job is only to love
this triggers mare to go to her best
friend and we see their heartfelt
reunion at laurie's house
it's heavy and powerful and is hands
down the most gripping scene in a series
that's had a lot of them
it opens the door for the closing
sequence where mare is sleeping with
drew in his bed
we see her walk into the hallway open up
the attic
and the series ends as she's finally
able to return to the place where the
paramedics had to wrestle her dead son's
body from her arms
in the end mare is able to confront
what's been hanging over her for years
and as she told mr carroll that pain
will probably never go away but at least
where she's at
now you can imagine things might get
better as a series
overall it was a lot of fun to engage
with the whodunit side of things
i had a blast breaking down the episodes
looking for clues
trying to solve it and reading
everyone's theories
plot-wise it mostly worked as you know
from watching my other videos i was a
skeptic about the ryan theory
but technically speaking they made it
work the breadcrumbs were there along
the way
everything falls into place when you
find out he's the killer
you can see how it played out and the
characters motivations and actions after
the fact
makes sense based on the situation
obviously in a mystery you have to have
misdirection
red herrings and twists and there seemed
to be a decision to betray scenes in a
way that you could draw multiple
conclusions
which can really add to that when it
works i think related to the plot there
are some of these that they didn't quite
pull off
like john exhibiting grooming behavior
with ryan
and dylan pointing the gun in jess's
face some of those things seem
misleading
after the fact but they're not
unforgivable
i appreciated the attempts to lighten
things up through humor
and a wonderful performance from gene
smart
the performances really are what stands
out by the end
as much as some of this finale didn't
work for me the individual character
moments
all worked and were moving when you look
at them on their own
and a lot of that comes back to the
performances and the choices and
direction
julianne nicholson essentially
collapsing going limp in kate winslet's
arms is something that will be burned in
my brain from this point forward
i think where the finale came up short
for me is something that worked really
well in the early episodes
the quick pace of moving from one thing
to the next adding layers to the mystery
without ever having to slow down to hit
the character moments
they nailed a balance of both elements
which is difficult to do
in the final episode it didn't work
nearly as well for me
and the character side of things
suffered as the big showpieces didn't
hit as hard as i would have expected
them to
after jon's arrested at the beginning of
the episode there's an expectation of a
twist coming
and that takes up a lot of space i think
this stood out the most when they had
that scene when they're out to eat with
frank and faye
there's this important family moment
between helen and mare
and it does work in that instant but it
almost feels out of place because
there's so much
other stuff going on you experience it
and then you instantly move on to what's
going on with this case that isn't quite
making sense mare was a great vehicle
for a talented actor to show off her
stuff in a different kind of role
and kate winslet did a terrific job
julianne nicholson gave her a run for
her money in the finale
and it was a hell of a cast across the
board if you just focus on mare's story
and that does seem to be what everything
else is there to serve
it was an interesting character study
and you wouldn't be wrong for enjoying
that
i found that it took me out of things
and made this a little hard to do
because of the writing decision to have
mayor break into the evidence room
and steal evidence and plan it on carrie
you have this small town where things
are not great you're touching on a lot
of difficult issues
the opioid crisis is a big part of that
and really no one is making it out of
this
so to me it seems like maybe don't make
the character that has a little bit of
power
a cop who abuses that to punch down and
then
suffers no consequences mare didn't lose
anything in that there was really no
self-reflection on it
she still got the kid carrie still
relapsed and that took away from the
character for me
i mean she went to therapy and sure that
worked out for her but they could have
found a different way to get her there
i think it was a smart decision to shift
the focus
on how solving the case affected mare
personally
considering that a lot of people did
figure out the twist on the murder ahead
of time
but i think the ending would have had a
lot more impact for me
if she hadn't planted the heroin it was
a fun ride though
and i enjoyed interacting with you so
let me know in the comments what did you
think of the finale
what did you think about the series
overall and what's on your mind now that
it's over
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
i'm not sure what i'll be covering next
i've been looking around
if there's something you're looking
forward to let me know about that in the
comments too
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon